one of my favorite media stories that's
going on right now is that the more
extreme than fox news right-wing media
they smell blood in the water
they are starting to sense fox news may
be bailing on donald trump now they
haven't bailed on trump to be very clear
fox news is still sucking up to trump
and i'm going to give you some examples
in a moment but one of the things that
is happening in the lead-up not not to
the 2022 midterms but to the 2024
republican primary is fox news wants an
off-ramp fox news wants to credibly be
able to get behind someone other than
donald trump if that is how the winds
turn and that person seems to be ron
desantis but fox isn't abandoning trump
right now they're just starting to play
up alternatives to trump including ron
desantis but
the other media outlets that want to
dethrone fox news as the
primary or most important right-wing
media outlet they smell blood in the
water and they're going after fox news
here is greg kelly on newsmax
accusing fox news of trying to cancel
donald trump this is good for the left
there's very little that's good for the
left right now but right wing media
going after each other
i'll take whatever we can get
tone it down a notch uh mr vice
president nice guy
i like lots of things about him but not
everything and not january 6 and not
this i think he's kind of faking it just
a little bit all right so they banged
the gong fox news alert for mike pence
donald trump spoke at 3 p.m
what happened then
it's a very important issue and a lot of
republicans believe that uh they don't
like the covet voting rules that were in
place so while donald trump was speaking
at a major event in washington d.c the
first time he went back to washington
since he left the presidency they had a
bunch of people
doing this how dare they not cover
trump's big speech uh no donald trump
again it's between the billionaires it's
personal okay there's something personal
and uh
i don't like it i don't think it's uh
fair to donald trump they're trying to
cancel him actually you know i knew the
left wing was trying to cancel him but
the
conservative media as well
check this out newsmax had the whole
thing
if i renounce my beliefs
have i agreed to stay silent imagine
bragging that you broadcast this
if i stayed at home
and just took it easy
the persecution of donald trump would
stop immediately would stop
but that's not what i will do i can't do
that
all right he spoke for about an hour and
40 minutes it was fascinating it was all
good stuff we carried it live right here
on newsmax
but again fox news did it they're trying
to cancel him conservative media tried
to cancel the former president now it is
not actually true that fox news has
turned on trump newsmax benefits from
that narrative understand that newsmax
has a vested interest in convincing
viewers that fox has turned on trump
because newsmax and fox share a lot of
viewers and if they are trumpist viewers
and they start to believe fox is now
anti-trump the only place to get my
pro-trump uh pablum is on newsmax it's
only good for newsmax's ratings now it's
not even really true okay fox news is
setting up an off-ramp that's all
they're doing but trump is furious about
it anyway the other day fox and friends
we played this clip they simply
mentioned poll numbers and trump lost it
you've got people from all across the
country convening in tampa
i am thinking about um
that is a little different than a couple
of other polls that we've seen over the
last couple of weeks two weeks ago in
florida blue point uh rather blueprint
polling did a poll
desantis leads the former president in
all age groupings
then there was a university of new
hampshire poll in june
desantis actually led trump 39-37
and that new york times siena
a college poll that we decided quite a
few times less than half of republican
voters back donald trump as their
preferred choice so it's like the young
people
who are activists at that event right
like the former president but looking at
these other polls
a different answer yeah if you look
state by state ron desantis is showing
tremendous strength in new hampshire
michigan and florida he's leading her
tied with the former president
and turning point run by charlie kirk
extremely impressive organization and
they are extremely enthusiastic and
active us
okay
so they just read poll numbers that's
all they did and trump flipped out trump
trump immediately went on truth social
and said fox and friends just really
botched my poll numbers no doubt on
purpose that show has been terrible
going to the dark side they quickly vote
the big turning point poll they quickly
quote the big turning point poll victory
of almost 60 points over the number two
republican and then hammer me with
outliers actually almost all polls have
me reading leading all republicans and
biden by a lot
rhino paul ryan one of the weakest and
worst speakers ever must be running the
plays anyway thank you to turning point
the crowd and love was amazing that's it
was so mild so mild and if you want
proof that they're not really turning on
trump
just look at this from the same episode
yeah donald trump is playing in the
pro-am today bryce and d chambeau and i
believe no not to say there everybody's
wearing almost the exact same clothes
but it's actually not the same episode i
apologize staying in the pro-am today
with bryson d chambeau and i believe
dustin johnson i i don't know who's
going to close out that scratch golfer
um he is right i believe they're all
good golfers i think he's the other one
i know he's the greatest golfing
president ever really
athletic that's right yeah very very
much a good golfer sucking up to him and
then uh here's another one where now fox
and friends is on the defensive
they talk about poll numbers
but then they remember
to say we didn't invent the numbers 55
percent of republicans or people leaning
republican
wants somebody other than donald trump
to run that's up six percent from their
earlier poll and if the former
president's watching you should know
those are the just the numbers you're
relaying you didn't come up with those
numbers right cnn came up with it
ainsley said if this was a fascinating
poll it is that's why we just talked
about it now i had to do the same thing
remember last week i told you guys that
joe biden's approval rating is in the
toilet
and people were furious at me for
reporting those numbers i actually
hilariously had to do the same
disclaimer where i was like guys i
didn't do the polling it's not
reflective of my opinion and they are
right as often as haley's comic comes by
every seven years so you're just saying
all we talked about for the last four
minutes is not accurate i'm just saying
it's donald trump trump is watching and
to see it if donald trump is watching
just let him know we didn't come up with
that number that's what the poll said
right absolutely
they're treating him like a little kid
it's it's amazing actually i was talking
to uh yeah yeah
i was talking to a pollster about these
numbers and they seem to be across the
board regarding some few people on the
democratic party want children it's just
too soon to tell there's so many
different polls and they all say
different
the
they are stumbling all over themselves
to avoid angering donald trump so listen
fox news hasn't fully turned on trump
fox news is setting up an off-ramp
that's what they're doing and newsmax is
trying to take advantage of it this is
the power struggle happening right now
within right wing media
i care about it to the extent that maybe
it's bad for republicans that would be
great
as many of you know i take my snacks
very seriously i avoid excess sugar and
junk food and so when i want something
sweet
i go to our sponsor monk pack monk pack
makes my favorite granola bars and nut
and seed bars if you're doing keto it
works just one gram of sugar or less
only two to three net carbs under 150
calories the flavors are delicious sea
salt dark chocolate that's my favorite
you've got your coconut cocoa chip
you've got your caramel sea salt the
texture the flavors this is a beautiful
granola bar and then you've got monk
packs nut and seed bars which are more
crunchy if you're craving something like
a crunchy chocolate candy bar
monk pack is the perfect thing to grab
instead same taste same experience none
of the carbs and sugars and calories
get 20 off your first order at
monkpack.com using the code pacman at
checkout the link is down below